one for one first year in as a coach
I believe to me
to me our voice
congratulations
you had such a beautiful emotional
moment up on that stage what was going
through your mind when they called your
name
[Laughter]
I did not expect that so I'm just very
grateful to be here has it hit you yet
um
[Music]
now you this one of course your first
year as a coach already taken a win home
you beat your TV dad but you did share a
special hug with him after she was
announced as the winner did he say
anything to you he said I thought you
everything you know
that's what he that's not even a joke
no no it was uh it was so special
um on Blake's last night and all of the
great tributes they had for him and some
of the Great Performances Adam CeeLo
everything it was just like it was such
a special night for him uh but it was
also fantastic to kick that man out the
door well you've told me that you and
him text non-stop are you worried it's
gonna go crickets now oh I've seen it
yes absolutely not yes I am
um no it's been it's been so fun like
getting to know Blake I've definitely
made a friend there there's there's no
doubt about it uh we're very similar
people like it or lump it
um but yeah listen tonight's about Gina
like she put in I can't think of a bad
performance that she's put in some most
of them you said some of them most of
them
um I know some of them are put in like
you know there's a performance every
week that you can be like ah you know
give or take
but this girl has just put in like Narco
after Narco every single time
um and I'm glad that the people got to
see
her for who she is and the voice that
she's got it's just it's incredible I'm
absolutely delightful America chose you
when you realize realize the magnitude
of that look that that's how does that
feel
she literally can't stop doing this
how will you celebrate
yeah
the thing is now it's like now is really
where the mentorship steps in after the
show how will you continue to be there
for her as her career continues yeah I'm
going to try and do my best of course
it's tough out there it's uh it's not
easy for any of us but I'm gonna try and
make sure that Gina gets looked after
in the right rooms
let her write from her heart and see
what happens and let the talent speak
for itself like it did here on The Voice
you're of course coming back next season
are you worried at all that your uh
chair the screws might be loose at all
because I feel like if anyone's got keys
for this place Blake might have some I
think he's already got the the chair
back at the house I think Glenn got it
yours yours yeah payback yeah mine won't
spin next season yeah exactly four days
of blind auditions just going like this
no turn
um
no it's a it's been a pleasure to share
with him it's been it's been a great
laugh I hope there's no loose balls but
let's hope I'll see you in July
guys congratulations
[Music]